はい、みなさんここまでのセッション、大変お疲れ様でした。
AIエージェントの基本的な仕組みからサブエージェントというかなり高度な構成まで一気に学んでいけたかなと思います。
さて、このセッションでは、皆さんが実際に自動化のワークフローを作成、開発していく上で、非常に重要になる注意点や基本的な流れについて学んでいきたいと思います。
このセッションが終われば、いよいよ皆さんですね、皆さんが本当に作りたいご自身のオリジナルのワークフローの作成に取り組んでいただく時間になります。
開発なんてやったことないのに、いきなりオリジナルなんて作れるかなと不安に思うかもしれないんですけども、ご安心いただけたらと思います。
なぜかというと、開発経験や特別な知識がなくても、今のこのAI時代のワークフローの開発を可能にする強力な基本ベースの考え方、どういうふうに作っていくかっていうフレームワークっていうのをご紹介したいと思います。
僕たちがですね提唱するAIワークフローの構築フレームワークっていうのはたったの4つだけになります。
まずは成功の定義ですね。PRD作成というふうに言うんですけども、まず何を作りたいか、どういうもの、どういう動きをするワークフローを作りたいかっていう目的と成果物を明確化しましょう。
それができたら、流用、ゼロから自分で全部考えて作る、ではなく、既存のリソース、テンプレートだったりとか、お手本っていうのを活用しましょうね、というところです。
それができたら、反復ですね。テスト、実行とかテスト、改善の繰り返しをやりましょう。
エラーが出た時にトラブルシューティングとしてどういうところがエラーになっているのか、どのワークフロー、どのノードが動いていないのかっていうのを問題を見つけるのとそれを解決していく。
たったのこれだけです。
この4つっていうのを順番にしっかり丁寧に回していくことで、どんな方でも必ず自動化の仕組みを完成させることができますよというところですね。
はいではそれぞれ詳しく解説していきたいとおもいます まずこの一つ目成功の定義
まずですね最も重要なのがこのPRD作成になります よくこう仕様書みたいなところなんですけども
要は何のためにどんな自動化を作りたいのかっていうのを自分の中でしっかりとはっきり させることなんですね
例えば毎朝のニュースを要約してSlackに通知をするみたいな目標であったりとか じゃあそのために必要なプロセスを一旦頭の中で考えてみましょう
ニュースサイトを見る記事を集めるそれを要約するSlackに送るみたいな感じで簡単に頭の中でワークフローを組んでみる
そのために必要なツールは、AI、要約するためのAI必要だな、Slackのノード必要だな、みたいな簡単な洗い出しをしておくことで、自分が今何を作っていて、どこを作っているのかっていうのをしっかり迷子にならずに進めることができますよというところですね。
その次、ステップ2としては流用になります。
これは自分でゼロから作らないよというところですね。皆さんが作りたいワークフローっていうのは、ほとんどの場合ですね、すでに世界の誰かが似たようなものを作っております。
n8nのテンプレートを見てみると、現時点で6000以上、ほぼ7000近いワークフローが公開されております。
この数字は日に日に増え続けているんですね。
まずはここで自分が使いたいツール、SlackとかGoogleシートとか、あとGmailとかややりたいこと、どういうのをやりたいかなっていうのを簡単にここで検索をしてみて、自分が作りたいものと似たワークフローというのを探しましょう。
ユーチューブとか他のネット上で公開されているチュートリアルとか、そういうのもあったりするので、そういうのを調べて活用するっていうのもかなりいい方法になるかなと思います。
そのような形でテンプレートだったりとか、他の人が作ったワークフローを見つけてきたら、いよいよ反復に入ります。
これはテストと改善を繰り返し行うプロセスなんですけども ここで非常に重要なポイントというのがあります
それは一つ修正を加えたら一度テストを実行するということです 例えばワークフローこのようにあったりとか
このようにあった際に 例えばここでエラーが起きているなとかこの部分でなんか赤くなっているなと思ったら
例えば10箇所赤くなっている。その10箇所全部自分流に修正してその最後にテスト実行しちゃうと、それでまたエラーが出た時にその10箇所のうちどこが原因だったのかというのがわからなくなってしまいますよね。
そのため、1つノードを追加したら、それを1つ1つテストしていく。1つ追加したら1つ実行。みたいな感じで、1つ1つ丁寧に追加していくことで、
結果的に一番最速でこのワークフローを完成させるというのができますので、一気に作って一気に実行して、エラーが出たらどこか分からないという状態にならないように注意をするのが大事だったりします。
そしてこの反復テストと改善の繰り返しをしているときに必ずと言っていいほど出会うのがエラーですね。
赤くなってエラーコードが出るときですね。つまりそのトラブルシューティングっていうのを自分でやる必要があります。
エラーが起きたときにその問題の原因を理解して解決策を実行するプロセスですね。
特にこの開発っていう経験が少ない方にとって、このAI時代におけるAIを使った反復とトラブルシューティングの方法を学ぶというのは、何よりも重要なスキルになります。
というわけで、ここからは皆さんと一緒にですね、このフレームワークのステップ3とステップ4、反復とトラブルシューティングに焦点を当てた演習というのを行っていきたいと思います。
今からですね、こちらの方でわざとエラーが出るようなもの、ワークフローというのをこちらで作成しました。
それを実行していただきたいと思うんですけども、こちらが指定するURLにアクセスしてワークフローのファイルをダウンロードしてください。
そして右上ですね、このボタンからImport from Fileというのを押してダウンロードしたものを開くと、このようなワークフローというのが出てくるかなと思います。
このワークフローもものすごくシンプルで、RSSトリガーで指定されたサイト、例えばヤフーニュースなどから情報を抽出して、このエディットのノードにつながっている、かなりシンプルなワークフローになっております。
これができたら、早速テスト実行をしてみましょう。
このようにこっちのノードでエラーが出ております。
しっかり成功せずにエラーが出て失敗していますよというふうな表示になっていると思います。
これで一応成功となります。
はい、エラーが出ましたね。
ここでフレームワークのステップ4ですね。
トラブルシューティングを行います。
こういうエラーが出たとき、全部英語だし分かりにくいなと思うかもしれないんですけども、僕たち、私たちには優秀な相談相手がいますよね。
それがGoogle AI StudioでGeminiを使う、あるいはChatGPTなど、皆さんがお持ちのChat AIですね、文章生成AIを開きます。
この時、AIに投げるプロンプトが、ものすごく重要になります。
以下の3点を必ず含めてください。
というのが、まずはエラーメッセージです。
この下の部分、アウトプットの部分のエラーの部分を押すと、こんな感じでかなり詳しくエラーっていうのがずらーっと出ています。
これもこの右上の部分からコピーができるので、それをコピーして、まずChatGPTなど、文書生成AIですね、に貼り付ける。
かなり長いものなんですけど、貼り付けて、次にワークフローの概要を送ります。
このワークフローのコード化したものですね。
これはダウンロードして保存できるんですけども、先ほどファイルで保存してこれ開いたと思うので、そのファイルっていうのをこのファイルの追加から添付します。
このような感じですね。JSONファイルというのを添付します。
そして、その最後、文章として、このエラーを解決したいです。
何がエラーになっていて、どのように解決すればいいか教えてくださいと伝えます。
少し待つと、このような感じで、ChatGPTが原因を洗い出してくれました。
ここを見てみると、原因はこのノードの値に入っている式の文法ミスです。
あなたのワークフローを見ると、ここの値が次のようになっていて、正しい書き方はこうですよというふうにいろいろ書き出してくれています。
これパッと見てちょっとわかんないなと思っても、下に修正手順っていうのをわかりやすく書いてくれているので、これ通りにやっていきたいと思います。
n8n、このノードを開くというところで、n8n、エラーが出ているこれを開いて、ここのノードですね、を開いて、
ここのテスト、バリューの右のFXをオン、値を上記の正しい式に差し替えると書いてあります。
ここの部分の文章というのを先ほどChatGPTが出してくれたこの正しい書き方をペーストします。
それが入力できたら一旦変更したところを修正して再度実行を行ってみます。
するとこのような感じでこのワークフローは成功しましたよ実行できましたよというふうな表示になります。
しかしここアウトプットを見てみると何も表示されていないのわかりますか。
このワークフローはこのニュースサイトですねからタイトルを引っ張ってきて表示させたい。
そんなワークフローになっているのにも関わらず、成功していると言っているけども、実際には成功していないみたいなことが起きております。
最初のここのフレームワークで成功の定義っていうのは最初に決めましょうとお伝えしましたよね。
今回のこのワークフローでの成功の定義は、抽出したニュースサイトのタイトルを抽出するというワークフローになっております。
そのため、このワークフロー自体が成功していても、結果的に自分が欲しい回答が得られていなかったら、それは失敗になってしまいますよね。
このステップ3とステップ4の反復とトラブルシューティングを繰り返す必要があります。
そしたら、またこの画面などをスクショ取ったりとか、このエラー、このワークフローというのをまたダウンロードして、
JSONコードにし、このような形で送って、このような形でワークフロー自体は成功したけどもタイトルが表示されませんよと、どのように改善したらいいですかみたいな形で、自分の求めている結果が出るまで、このChatGPTとかGeminiなどと壁打ちをしてどんどん解決をしていく。
そんな流れで、この一つのフレームワークというのを完成させる必要があります。
というところで、こちらの方でいろいろChatGPTと壁打ちして、先ほど表示されなかった部分、このように改善しました。
これで実行をしてみると、しっかりと成功して、このアウトプットの部分を見てみると、
しっかりと抽出したニュースサイトのタイトル、ここのタイトルの部分ですね、がこちらにも表示されているので、このワークフローでニュースサイトからいろんなニュースを抽出して、一つタイトルを出す。
そのタイトルをここに表示をさせるという一つのワークフローが完成しました。
最終的にですね、タイトルを正しく抽出する方法をAIに見つけてもらって、ワークフローが意図した通りに動けば、この演習は完了になります。
はい、いかがでしたでしょうか。
この演習でAIとの対話において、こちらの意図、目的というのを明確に伝えるプロンプトがいかに重要か。
このような体感をいただけたかなと思います。そしてもう一つ大事なアドバイスとしては、エラーが起きたとき、AIの回答というのは素晴らしいヒントになるんですけども、それと同時にn8nの基本的なデータの流れを理解する、自分も理解していくというのが、中性を簡単にする重要な鍵になります。
この前のノードですねから次のノードへデータが正しく渡されているのか こういったしっかり
こっちのノードのアウトプットと次のノードのインプット そしてアウトプット
っていう このデータですね
どのノードまで正しく動いているかなっていう確認をする癖をぜひつけていただけたらいいかなと思います。
そして今後はAIを使って こうした書き方
やさらに一歩進んでn8nで使える簡単なコードJavaScriptとかいうものですね
このn8nの講座では、ノーコードプラットフォームにおけるデータフローの構造を学んできました。
データがRSSフィードから取り込まれ、ノードで処理され、結果が出力される。
そんなコードの知識がなくても、こうした論理的な思考でワークフローを構築できる点が、このn8nの本当に画期的な部分になります。
そしてAIを活用しながら、エラーの対処や改善を反復することによって、その論理構造への理解というのは、皆さんが思うよりもずっと早く深まっていきます。
AIはあくまでヒントや選択肢を提供してくれる優秀なアシスタントです。
そのAIが出してくれた選択肢やヒントっていうのをどう採用し、どう修正するのか、その最終的な判断というのは必ずあなた自身、人間が行う必要があるんですね。
この感覚を忘れずに、ぜひ皆さんのオリジナルのワークフロー構築にチャレンジをしてみてください。